he needs to deal with the protocol
because my
fear has always been that the protocol
will narrow
the common ground in northern ireland
and i think we've seen that
over the past six months and so we need
now
to continue the work that we've been
doing over the past six months
i think both the prime minister and lord
frost have been
listening they have been putting out
some very good statements in relation to
dealing with the protocol but now we
need to see action
and we need to see action quite soon
because every day
the protocol remains the way it is uh
there's more damage done to northern
ireland
and how are the talks going david frost
said that you might have to invoke
article 16 if
discussions without trade don't get
sorted indeed
and that may well be the case we have
said all along when
the european commission tried to invoke
article 16 at the end of january that
the europeans were quite happy to do it
in terms of vaccines and making sure
that they had enough vaccines
this is doing real damage to northern
ireland in terms of our trade
but also in terms of the union and
therefore
the prime minister needs to act and i
hope that lord for us will bring forward
proposals very very soon
how damaging will it be for ireland
well as i've said every day that the
protocol is in place
does more damage to northern ireland in
terms of our trading relationship with
our
largest partners in great britain and of
course
it does damage to the union as well and
i my real concern
as i move to leave office is the fact
that
actually it's narrowing the common
ground in northern ireland and that's a
real concern
how damaging is brexit well i think
you have to separate brexit and protocol
the protocol
is doing the damage to northern ireland
of course i believed in brexit because i
believed that we needed to leave the
european union and all of the
stringent rules that were there to allow
us to be more flexible to allow us to
have a place in the world
but if the united kingdom is to have a
new place in the world northern ireland
must be part of that
and a present because of the protocol or
not and as you were
on your final day how do you feel with
mr boots taking your place
well you know it's uh my final day
probably coming up
into downing street as the first
minister and his dup leader
but i hope it's not my final day in
downing street at all he has said that
yeah he'd want you to leave earlier you
know for
a smoother transition would you do that
well look i haven't been speaking to
edwin i haven't had any contact from him
but i'm sure he will speak to me in due
course
well look i got into politics to make
northern ireland a better place
to move northern ireland forward i
believe
if we are to do that and continue to do
that then i think we need to deal with
the protocol
in a very proactive way and i hope that
when i speak to the prime minister this
morning
we'll hear more about that thanks very
much